هذه الازقه بحي القصبه في الجزائر العاصمه
كانت ديكورا لافلام جزائريه خالده انتجت
مباشره بعد الاستقلال
[موسيقى]
في المعرفه الجزائر الحائز على جائزه
الاسد الذهبي في مهرجان البندقيه وفي
الوقائع سنين الجمر المتوج بالسعفه
الذهبيه في مهرجان كان صار من ارشيف
السينما الخالد فقد زوجت تلك الاعمال بين
سينما الذاكره والتحولات الاجتماعيه في
تلك الفتره السينما الجزائريه
كان لها شهيده عصرا ذهبيا اصبحت في مثابه
ارشيف جمع هنا على مستوى المركز الجزائري
للسينما تقلص عدد قاعات السينما الى نحو
20 نتيجه لانتكاسه السينما الجزائريه خاصه
في التسعينيات فقد تخلت الحكومه عن الدعم
المالي للافلام وتدهور التكوين وغادر ابرز
المخرجين الى
الخارجت على هذا القطاع هذا اصبح يعني
سينما صفحه عاجزه انها تقوم بالواجب
بتاعها بغض النظر عن القاعات السينما اي
شيء اللعب
تقدم السلطات حاليا مقاربه اقتصاديه
للسينما في ردها على مخاوف عبر عنها
سينمائيون بعد ايقاف صندوق الدعم الحكومي
العام الماضي هناك وعي ضمني لدى الحكومه
في مرافقتها ودعمها لكل المشاريع
السينمائيه حتى تجعل من المبدع سينمائي
متحرر من كل القيود البيروقراطيه بالاساس
وكذلك انه يحاول ان يتناغم كذلك مع هذه
النظره المستجده في جعل من المنجز
السينمائي منجزا همم يحمل ابعد الاقتصاديه
في خضم التحولات التي يمر بها الفن السابع
برزت الحاجه الى المزيد من المهرجانات
السينما لرصد الانشغالات والاجوبه
والانجاز
يطمحوا مخرجون ومبدعون الى استعاده
السينما الجزائريه مجدها الذي صنعه وهجو
القضيه الوطنيه حينها لكن الظروف تغيرت
منذ اذن وحتى يتحقق ذلك الطموح يؤكد
النقاد واهل الفن السابع على ضروره توفر
عوامل صناعه سينمائيه حقيقيه
الجزيره الجزائر